how much can you make on YouTube I'm
going to break into the numbers with you
today hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I got a
great question today front of my Twitter
followers love you guys
muscle company who wrote in to say is
monetizing YouTube videos necessary or
worth it how do you find usable songs
that don't break copyright rules so this
is a fantastic question and one I think
every youtuber at one point thinks about
or new youtubers are thinking about
because they want to get on YouTube how
much money can I make now on average a
youtuber will make two dollars and 50
cents for every thousand views on their
videos
that's after YouTube takes their cut you
are making two dollars and fifty cents
for every thousand views on your channel
so if you want to look at any famous
youtuber go to their channel see how
many views are getting and you can
estimate that on average they're making
whatever number of views they have
divided by a thousand times 2.5 that's
how much money they're making when I
first heard that number I was kind of
shocked because my chair earns a lot
more than 250 per thousand and that may
be because my niche is more focused on
entrepreneurs and business that on
stupid cat tricks or some other fun
things that aren't as related to
business I never got into this just
trying to make a lot of money off of
Adsense but picking the right niche can
help make you a lot more profitable the
next thing you want to watch out for is
copyright claims if any part of your
video is using a song or video footage
or pictures that somebody else owns you
could potentially get a copyright claim
striked against you what that means is
whoever owns the copyright to that
footage that you're using has the choice
to either block your content in certain
countries block your content worldwide
or let the content stay up but any money
that's made from the video goes to them
and not you so I have some popular
videos on my channel that I can't
monetize because it's using third-party
footage and any ads that you see on
there is giving them money not me I also
have videos that aren't very popular
that had copyright strikes against them
on my recent trip to Disney World I
spent a few seconds on the video singing
the frozen song let it go
and then I got this email from YouTube
saying that because I use let it go my
video couldn't be monetized my whole
video can't be monetized for me because
I'm using a few seconds of somebody
else's song so the way around it is to
use a library that YouTube gives you a
free songs that you can use or you can
subscribe to websites where you get
royalty-free music that you can upload
or you can also partner up with local
artists who want to get their tracks out
there and you can give them some
exposure for it the real way to make
money though on YouTube is to sell other
products and services it's to build up
an audience and a following that you can
then sell your products to or that other
people would be interested in reaching
so for me I have my zuga guides that I
sell the entrepreneurs I have an online
coaching program that I work with
entrepreneurs through and I also work
with big brands who are trying to reach
entrepreneurs and I may make videos for
them on my channel just as an example
when I'm making a video with a brand my
starting price would be $1,500 I would
never make that kind of money from
Adsense on that video but because I have
a following of people who they're trying
to reach they're willing to pay me to
create this video for my channel it's
just like writing the book when you
write a book you don't make a lot of
money with a publisher you might only
make a dollar or less for every book
that's sold but the real money is in the
promotion the exposure the speaking gigs
the brand deals that you can make as a
result of having a published book so if
you want to do the math you can expect
to earn around 2 dollars and 50 cents
for every thousand views on your videos
remember to watch out for copyright
claims and only use content that you're
allowed to use and focus on building an
audience and you can then sell other
products and services to believe thank
you for watching I'd love to know how
you are making money through your
youtube channel leave a comment below
and spread some love and spread some
knowledge so that other people can learn
from you as well if you like this video
you want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and to the
newsletter thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon